los tres mensajes principales fueron los
siguientes primero gratitud a estas a
estas personas a estos primeros personas
que estaban en la primera línea de
respuesta frente a la pandemia en estos
casi 16 meses de pandemia que ha habido
eeuu pues el presidente bailén quiso
agradecerles haber puesto en riesgo sus
vidas para tratar de ayudar a las
familias y a las personas más afectadas
en esta pandemia fue entonces este
mensaje de gratitud a los primeros
respondiste si a las fuerzas militares
que estuvieron ahí presentes
estos son sobre todo los invitados gente
que estuvo en la primera línea y
militares los que están en este momento
en la casa blanca celebrando esta gran
barbacoa esta gran fiesta que pues nos
tenía acostumbrados
georges de bollywood wigan también y sus
fiestas pero que don 8 no durante sus
cuatro años de gobierno nos celebró no
hizo estas fiestas en el en la zona sur
de la casa blanca el segundo mensaje
pues es lamentar las a más de 600 mil
muertes que han sufrido
eeuu precisamente por el cahuite y el de
mencionó obviamente el tema de la nueva
variante la variable la variable
la variante delta perdón y pues el
tercer mensaje es pedirle implorarle a
los estadounidenses que por favor se
pongan la vacuna usted ha mencionado
bien cerca del 67 por ciento de los
estadounidenses tiene al menos una
vacuna pero pues no llega o apenas
supera el 50 por ciento los
estadounidenses que tienen ya las dos
vacunas están completamente vacunados
así que es un gran reto que tiene yo
bailé para lograr ese 70 por ciento o
más que según pues el docentes de salud
en eeuu es la cifra clave para asegurar
esa inmunidad de rebaño se hará la
fiesta en los contados minutos empiezan
ya entonces los fuegos artificiales en
la casa blanca- fuegos artificiales que
comparado al año anterior le mencionaba
durarán a cerca de 17 minutos el año
anterior durante la administración de
donald trump pues fueron 35 minutos de
fuegos artificiales pero pues el
ambiente obviamente
es bastante más tranquilo bastante más
normal a lo que se vivió el año anterior
en plena pandemia y precisamente ese era
uno de los mensajes principales también
en este discurso tratar de transmitirles
desde la casa blanca desde los
organismos de control de salud a los
estadounidenses que la cosa va bien y
que pronto se va a poder lograr llegar a
la normalidad de hoy un último dato en
20 estados aquí en eeuu ya se logró
precisamente esa cifra de el 70 por
ciento de adultos vacunados pero pues
obviamente quedan 30 31 estados que no
logran esa cifra y ahí entonces queda es
el reto para eeuu